seeing my brother go through his process
of getting married and all that stuff it
definitely brings back the feelings like
that i had
going through yeah oh my gosh
[Music]
hello
trying to everybody down luca
i'm also trying to iron people's clothes
because we don't have enough steamers
yeah so casey and carrie are getting
haircuts right now and
i
am looking like this wearing the same
clothes as i did yesterday but look at
that he looks so cute i actually got him
a little suit with a tiny little tie
it's so adorable so that's what he's
gonna wear later by the way tonight is
the dinner rehearsal slash welcoming
dinner thing
for their guests so that's why we're
trying to get ready but tomorrow is a
big wedding day
oh
oh
oh
no
what happened
i think what happened is that when i put
it down and i plugged it in i didn't
check to see if it was on or off oh
clearly looks like it's been on because
oh
we burnt the crap out of this and it
smells disgusting so
this is gross you know they have a
pregnancy brain or mommy brain there's a
bridal brain he's like i have a baby
brains on you
yeah mommy brain baby brain bridal brain
all right today is the day that we are
getting ready for the wedding for
tomorrow
oh yeah
so today is the day that we're doing the
rehearsal dinner and uh everyone's all
dressed up including luca they look so
good yeah they're matching they both got
some blue i don't have a tie though
[Music]
when he breaks that smile that's the
most yeah from that face
to a smile break this when you pick
smile i don't want to give it to you
right now
there you go he's like oh you want this
note so we are currently at the location
of the wedding that's going to take
place tomorrow we're going to be taking
pictures i think oh no i think we're
doing the t-star money right now oh is
that what we're doing here okay i forget
good thing we're not the wedding planner
i know this place is so beautiful and it
literally takes me back to our wedding
because it's like really similar vibes
and like the layout too is really
similar this is really cute it's like i
don't know it's kind of like
transporting us back to five years ago
you know what about us driving up here
what did i what did i do driving up here
oh yeah and then casey was playing the
playlist that we curated around the time
that we got married so like we call it
our wedding playlist
[Music]
look at look how you're like
[Music]
what do you think of the wedding so far
so isaac is the ring bearer so he's got
a really important job how to kill the
bb ring bearer feels good
i didn't get to do it for you guys no
that you had a more important job which
was to bring me up down the aisle that's
way more important than the ring
[Music]
i don't know
[Music]
all right we are at
carrie and diana's uh welcoming dinner
welcoming dinner look at this boy what's
up my boys all three of my boys you guys
look so cute we clean up pretty nicely
don't we luca
[Music]
man i wish we got our wedding like in an
area like this
this is why newport's more expensive
because you get this view
ah so this is the place you would want
to have had your
place but just newport in general has
like this side of the view with the nice
bridge and everything oh i see like more
more like cliff
like yeah
but either way i'm having a great time
still get to enjoy this nice view
definitely all right so we're doing the
what now it's a tea ceremony
at your wedding but way more casual oh
god we weren't prepared we didn't bring
a teapot or anything so we bought like a
little sake set hey
let's turn up while we're doing it are
you are you orchestrating the tea
ceremony yeah that's what i heard i
don't know do you know what you're doing
no not really yes perfect i've only ever
seen it
you know what you're doing then all you
have to do is see it once in my hand
yeah but i have to like talk to the gym
you know she originally asked me to
officiate it but then i'm in it so then
i was but even though i've been in one
like i wouldn't know how to do it either
in this podcast you can like talk oh i'm
gonna be like i'm like wait wait
you look like you know what you're doing
i don't know
you match the teeth and everything like
the strawberries
this is your mom's decoration oh
strawberry infused tea yeah i'm gonna
try something
sounds good it looks really bushy
oh i don't drink it you drink it we've
been going through a lot in the last
seven years good time tough time
argument
a fun time
but we hope you
have a merry
marriage
[Applause]
this is a happy day wish you guys have a
happy marriage
uh keep growing your happiness you know
be productive work hard we are always
here to support you guys so you know
cheer to the chain cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
good
morning
all right so um
what's happening here what's happening
over there so baba is working on ac unit
in isaac's room because last night isaac
was trying to close the window no it's
wrong he's trying to open the window
trying to like close it but i guess my
hand like went up and the way this thing
is hold up it clamps with it it has to
have a window closed and hold this in
place
yeah if you raise it
it will lose the anchor and then the
thing would just fall off the window and
that's exactly what happened it fell out
the window so i was in the room next
door getting luca's bath ready oh my
baby might be smiling and then i hear
the ac unit on but then i hear like
like some like rumble i guess it's like
the window and then i just hear the ac
in it like
the actual ac unit being on but like
[Music]
we got pretty lucky uh with it falling
on the trash cans because the trash cans
broke the fall of the ac unit and that
way
uh the ac unit looks pretty good no i
don't have enough tools to make this
work
all right that needs more tools so yeah
he's trying to fix it because the entire
and then the other part that i thought
was hilarious it was the fact that
the plug was still plugged into the wall
i yanked out the entire wire it just
gained it
yeah i was like oh man the paid to
replace that and i was like
you don't have to pay for anything i'm
gonna fix it it's only okay well we
already paid for two screwdrivers
i'm gonna talk quieter actually because
uh the owners
are downstairs so i don't to talk about
how we did all this
we're going to try and leave this place
as if nothing ever happened so
i'll try and fix it put it back in the
window pretend that happened
i know look at this book that we got
from luca
so it says gustavo the shy ghost or i'm
walking by a bookstore and we saw it
there like on the what's it called the
display or whatever i was like oh my god
it's gustavo my dad's name
and it's a ghost because we're in salem
so it's like a little like souvenir
um so i thought it was really cute and
it's also like mexican
like yeah all the stars aligned where
this like just comes off very meaningful
right and then also like we don't know
if my dad's a ghost or not yeah so
it's it's uh luca's way of meeting his
grandfather yeah
are you sitting up yet luca look are you
sitting up
he's sitting with like very minimal
support
[Music]
all right
here we go look at this got my makeup
done
lashes hair i'm feeling really hollywood
glam but let's check in with the bride
it's your wedding day hi
you excited i'm so excited i honestly
just cannot wait to like get out of here
just to like be in the car and like
start heading over there are you keeping
this is this here something blue i feel
like i should keep this so that's gonna
be my something borrower yes this is my
this is my blue like a royal royal oh
that's pretty this is actually the first
gift that carrie ever gifted me like
ever like whenever we were first dating
for those of you that don't know this
bracelet casey gave to me in one of our
first christmases together and i wore
the christmas that i met you oh yeah i
think it was yeah and i wore this for
the tea ceremony and i was gonna wear it
for the actual wedding but then during
the tea ceremony i got gifted a silver
bracelet so i changed it but yeah this
is my something but from my wedding
so cute we'll see if it looks good with
your dress if you like it yeah i mean if
it doesn't we'll just take it off yeah
no big deal i'm excited
it's such a momentous occasion
what are we still doing here yeah what
are we going to go let's go let's go
hello
your hair looks funny
happy wedding day thank you thank you
you look good yeah let me check on diana
thank you
do i look good
you do it all looks up here we're
running errands all morning so i didn't
really trying to fix that ac unit
yes yes
no no we're gonna eat tomorrow i don't
know
luca
hey
hi baby
hi my love
you're sleepy all right so i'm in the
car with dan and carrie and where are we
at oh we are at glen manor and i'm so
impressed
with the windmill
i can't
hey are y'all getting nervous at all
no no nervousness at all
[Music]
right right yeah
that's where the real stress is
no one else cares as much as we do
basically yeah
everyone's like all while we gagging
around we're like we gotta
[Music]
me so i didn't get to check it out
before doing it
it's all there
[Laughter]
you look so
[Music]
look at beautiful
look at this handsome board look at the
shoes yeah so from head to toe you have
to shoot up from head to toe head
we got the bow tie we got the suspenders
the white shirt the trousers we got the
shoes and the dress socks yeah i found
baby dress socks how cute is that
[Music]
all right my baby what you got got the
rings right here about to give the
couple uh their signal of a marriage
yeah what the [ __ ] their symbol of
marriage it's a very important job baby
are you gonna carry your brother oh
you're you're practicing to propose what
was that
[Music]
you're good
[Music]
it's my distinct honor to now pronounce
you
husband and wife you may kiss your bride
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the party
us
[Laughter]
no one's drinking yes
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye